نفسي احضن ابويا وارجع له وارجع لحضنه انا
وابويا واخوتي وامي
وعمامي احنا كثير شفنا حاجات
[موسيقى]
مرعبه انا زهوه ففرج
السموني طبعا احنا نازحين من غزه احنا
كنا منطقه الزيتون ح كنا اتجهوا الى
الجنوب في المكان الان
اتجهنا الى الجنوب واحنا جايين عبرونا من
حاجه اسمها الممر الامن وهذا بالنسبه ي
يعني الممر المخيف جدا لانه يعني
فينيه شفت حاجات
مرعبه قضيه مش عندي يعني انا اشتقت لحضنه
عن جد حضنه
دافي اخذو اليهود واحنا جايين عن مر اللي
بسموه الممر
الامن هدول الدفاتر احنا بنرسم عليهم
الرسمات اللي شفناهم في الحرب والوجع اللي
شفناه قدام عينينا لما اخذوا ابويا طبعا
احنا رسمنا حاجات كثير ه كانوا الدبابات
بيمشوا عننا وهذه كانت ال وهذا
السجن وهذا ابويا يعني انه كان محبوس هنا
ربنا
يرجعك النا بالسلامه يا بابا
وهنا خوخ كانوا ه مقصين علينا وهنا كانوا
الناس بيمشوا واحنا جايين ه كانوا يعني في
200 جسس و هيك وهنا كانت الطياره فوق
روسنا يعني كل يوم بقى شفف حلو
يعني انا كثير اشتقت لبابا بدي انا
ابويا